We have a voicemail number.
That number is two one nine two David P..
Here's something great.
A self-described boomer called into the show.
This woman is delightful.
She has the requisite David Pakman show playing
in the background while she leaves the voicemail.
This is just a classic now for David Pakman
show callers.
We had a call last week from someone who said,
why aren't the boomers out protesting?
And I pointed out, you know, it always tends
to be younger populations that disproportionately
protest up.
And we have a pandemic that disproportionately
affects older folks.
So it seems totally expected and reasonable
that we're not seeing as many baby boomers
out protesting.
Check out this voicemail from my new favorite
David Pakman show caller.
Hi.
I'm a boomer.
I'm 68 years old.
And you know what?
There are a lot of boomers out there protesting.
But those of us who have all mascotry disease
and who are extremely vulnerable to the corona
virus really hesitate about putting ourselves
into big groups of people, of course.
So anyway, that's my two cents makes absolute
perfect sense.
Delightful self-described boomer with The
David Pakman Show playing in the background.
You were completely right.
And this was exactly what I said.
And it just makes sense.
And listen, after what happened to Martin,
Guggi, no 75 year old protester who got knocked
down by police hit the back of his head, bled
from his ear and spent nearly a week in the
hospital.
If you're going to assume that as an older
person, the police won't manhandle you.
That is not being borne out.
We have at least a half a dozen incidents,
including the elderly man walking with a cane.
I forget where maybe it was Atlanta, although
if it wasn't, I apologize.
Who was knocked down by police?
There's a bunch of these incidents.
So I. I don't believe for a second that the
so-called boomers necessarily don't support
what's going on, but they seem to understand
the risks associated with gathering and large
crowds.
We're seeing what's happening in Texas, Florida,
as they've reopened spiking cases.
It's ugly.
So I totally understand and respect what they're
doing.
Here's something fun.
It's.
Things are so negative lately.
Come on and do something fun.
Tuesday night.
This is Tuesday, June 16, 8:00 p.m. Eastern
time, 8:00 p.m. Eastern, 5:00 Pacific.
David Pakman show chess tournament number
two.
I don't care if you have never played chess.
I mean, you want to know how the pieces move.
But the point is open to all skill levels.
Join the tournament.
We will be streaming it live at 8:00 p.m.
Eastern.
But you don't have to just watch me play in
the tournament.
You can play in it.
You can register on Lee Chess, dawg, so that
you're ready to go.
That's Ally Chess dot org.
It's going to be great.
We had five hundred people roughly play last
time.
I'm hoping that we do far better than that
this time.
And of course, remember that we have a daily
free podcast that you can sign up for on Spotify,
Apple II tunes, Google Play, et cetera, et
cetera, et cetera.
The Daily Audio Podcast.
Another great way to receive the show on today's
bonus show.
We will be covering Dr. Anthony Fouche, his
latest Corona virus comments.
We will talk about U.S. soccer lifting the
ban on kneeling during the national anthem.
And Amazon has banned police use of its face
recognition technology for a year.
Is this PR, B.S. or significant?
All of those stories and more on today's bonus
show.
Become a member.
Join Patman dot com.
And we'll see you on the bonus show for tomorrow